-Welcome back.
We're here with Chrissy Teigen,
and we're about to play a game
called "Best, Worst, First."
Here we go.
-♪ Unh, let me hear your ♪
-♪ Best, worst, first ♪
-Alright, now,
here's how it works.
I'm gonna hit this button,
which will activate
a random topic generator.
It'll land on a random prompt,
like best pickup line
you've ever used
or worst lie you ever told.
Whatever it lands on,
you have to say the first thing
that comes to your mind.
Are you ready?
-Okay. Ready.
-Here we go.
First up is "Best."
[ Digital tones playing ]
Best...
Best celebrity encounter.
-Oh, God.
Um... [ Laughs ]
God, I think it was after
the Golden Globes...
[ Laughing ] Oh, no.
This might be "worst."
I was drinking a lot
and I saw somebody
at the entrance
holding a glass of champagne,
so I just went up and I took it
and I said thank you,
and then John goes,
"That was Michael Keaton."
[ Both laugh ]
It was not...
-It was not someone
serving champagne?
-No, it was not.
And I'm so embarrassed by it
still.
-Oh, my...
-I could die.
-Well, at least
it's Michael Keaton.
He'll be a good sport about it.
He'll be funny and be like,
"What was that all about?"
-But I just, I took it,
I drank it, and I left.
-I'll take that answer.
I love that story.
And it's a good person to do
that to 'cause he's funny.
Alright, here we go.
Next round.
It is time for "Worst."
Here we go.
[ Digital tones playing ]
Worst...
Worst job you ever had.
The worst job you ever had.
-Um...I don't know...
if it necessarily had been
the worst,
but I had a job at
a color-changing T-shirt shop.
And I'd have to stand outside
and lure people inside
and say like, "Come check
this out! Check this out!
Check this out!
Check this T-shirt out!
This nail polish changes!"
And it was just, like,
outlined shirts
that I had to sell.
And, but the worst part was
that I actually quit my job
because I got this big --
Oh, yeah! This is the worst job!
I thought I had
this big opportunity
to be in a Red Bull commercial.
But it turns out they just
wanted me to be one of those
girls on the beach that wear,
like, the thick flip-flops
and give out Red Bulls.
So, I quit my entire job just
to give out free Red Bulls
during the U.S. Open of Surfing.
[ Laughs ] And I thought it was,
like, my big break.
I was like, "Finally,
I'm going to Hollywood!"
-I'm gonna be on
a commercial for --
Like, yeah, no, you're just
wearing big flip-flops.
-Remember those thick
flip-flops, the Rocket Dogs?
-Yep. Oh, my God.
-And they had studs on them.
And then I wore, like,
a schoolgirl black skirt
on the beach, and a bikini top,
giving out Red Bull.
Oh, my God.
-Hey, man.
Honestly, we all have
a story, right?
Oh, my gosh. I'm surprised we
didn't run into each other,
'cause I had the same job
that summer.
[ Both laugh ]
Okay.
-The skirt and all?
-Oh, yeah.
Everything, yeah, of course.
Last round. Here we go.
It is time for "First."
[ Digital tones playing ]
-Oh, God.
-Chrissy Teigen, first...
[ Gasps ] Oh, your first kiss.
Do you remember your first kiss?
-Oh, my God,
should I say his name?
Are people gonna try
to find him?
My first kiss was actually
at my -- after...
Oh, I went on a date
to Red Robin,
and it was, like,
the nice Red Robin.
We went, like, to the further
Red Robin.
-Yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
And then he dropped me off
at, actually, my best friend
Bonnie's house,
and she -- because her parents
were really cool,
and I don't think
I told my parents.
So, we went back there,
he walked me to the door,
and he was, like, a basketball
player at our school,
and it was just so...
He was not, like --
I don't know,
he was just such a nice guy.
-Did you feel it was coming that
you were gonna have a kiss?
-No, no, but I remember
how giddy I was after.
I was so excited.
And then nothing happened,
though, after.
Like, not a thing.
-Yeah.
-Not a -- Like, no --
Like, at school,
we didn't talk anymore.
[ Both laugh ]
-That's how you know it's
a first kiss, of course, right?
That's exactly what happens.
-We pretended nothing happened.
-Yeah, you don't even
say hi to each other.
That was over.
You had your moment.
That was it.
-[ Laughing ] I know.
-Pal, thank you for playing.
That was "Best, Worst, First."
Chrissy Teigen, you can check
out her new online store
Cravings shop at
cravingsbychrissyteigen.com.
We love you, bud.
Best to the fam.
Hug everybody.
-Love you, too, Jimmy.
-Stick around, we'll be right
back with more "Tonight Show."
Come on back!